محمود هل تستهدف اسرائيل اسرها حسب قانون
هني بعل بالفعل عاد الجدل بشان قانون هني
بعل مؤخرا مع تصاعد العمليات العسكريه هذا
القانون كان يسمح للجيش الاسرائيلي
باستخدام القوه المفرطه تجاه مجموعه خاطفه
حتى وان ادى ذلك الى قتل مخطوف ولكن هنالك
ثلاثه امور رئيسيه يجب التعريج عليها من
وجهه نظر المحللين والخبراء اولا هذا
القانون لم ينجح وفشل في الوصول الى الهدف
الهدف كان هو عدم جعل اسرائيل تدفع ثمنا
عاليا لقاء تحرير الجندي لكن باستخدام هذا
القانون حتى وان تم تحييد او قتل المجموعه
الخاطفه مع المخطوف فان الجثه تبقى لدى
الخصم وبالتالي لازال هناك ثمن سياسي يجب
دفعه للمقايضه بهذه الجثه اضافه الى ان
استخدام القوه المفرطه في عدل بعض
العمليات ادى الى سقوط قتلى بشكل كبير جدا
بين المدنيين ووضعها تعت ضغط دولي هذا
اولا لذلك هذا يقودنا الى ثانيا الصحف
ووسائل الاعلام العبريه قالت انه تم وقف
العمل بهذا القانون واستبداله بنظام اخر
للجيش الاسرائيلي هذا النظام يسمح
باستخدام القوه المفرطه تجاه مجموعه خاطفه
لكن مع تحييد الخطر تجاه المخطوف هناك
تشكيك بهذا الامر كيف يمكن استخدام القوه
المفرطه مع تحييد الخط عن المخطوف وهنا
ناتي الى الجزء الثالث العمليات الحاليه
بها اكثر من 100 اسير متوزع جغرافيا على
مساحه عاليه هذا عسكريا يعني انه قد يتم
استخدام قوه مفرطه على مساحه واسعه جدا
ولكن هذه القوه المفرطه لا تعني نجاح
العمليات في الحقيقه نسبه نجاح مثل هذه
العمليات سيكون ضئيلا جدا وقد يصل الى
الصفر وهنا تاتي مفارقه في المعادله
السياسيه هذا سيؤدي الى جعل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يبدو وكانه لا يكترث بحياه
الاسرى يقوم
بعمليه واسعه النسق فيها الكثير من القوه
الناريه غير المتكافئه يسقط فيها ضحايا
مدنيون ولا ينجح في تحقيق هدفه السياسي
فبالتالي معادله الاسرى ستكون حاضره جدا
في العمليات العسكريه وسير الحرب اضافه
الى المفاوضات السياسيه لاحقا